cuando por primera vez aprendemos a
multiplicar y dividir números positivos
y negativos
vimos que si tú tienes un número
positivo y lo multiplicas por otro
número positivo eso será igual a un
número positivo pero también es cierto
que si tú tienes un número negativo
y lo multiplicas por otro número
negativo eso también es igual a un
número positivo y la manera como tú
obtienes un número negativo es si
multiplicas o divides algo con signos
distintos entonces si tú tienes un
número positivo y lo multiplicas por un
negativo esto te da un negativo o si
tienes un negativo y lo multiplicas por
un número positivo eso también te da un
negativo esto es igual a un negativo y
bueno aquí lo escribí para
multiplicación pero también aplica para
la división si yo tengo un número
negativo y lo divido entre un número
negativo eso es positivo y si yo tengo
un número negativo lo divido entre un
positivo eso es negativo ahora aquí
estamos solamente multiplicando
dividiendo dos cosas pero qué pasaría si
yo divido a un multiplico entre tres
números cuatro números cinco números o
en cantidad de números la que sea que es
lo que se esperaría
entonces digamos que yo quiero
multiplicar tres números tengo el número
a y uso la anotación del punto para la
multiplicación si yo te digo que a b y c
son tres números positivos entonces tú
sabes que el producto a por b por ser
eso sería positivo a por b sería
positivo y eso por c donde se es
positivo sería positivo pero qué pasaría
si yo te digo que todos estos números
son negativos entonces supongamos que a
veces son números negativos menores que
0 en este caso que resulta del producto
ok vamos a analizar esto así que aquí
tienes un número negativo a es un número
negativo y lo vamos a multiplicar por b
otro número negativo
negativo x negativo eso es igual a un
positivo entonces esto es positivo
a por ver es positivo
entonces aprobé eso es positivo pero eso
lo vamos a multiplicar por se dice es un
número negativo entonces tú tienes aquí
positivo por negativo esto será un
negativo será menor que cero así que si
a veces son números negativos su
producto será menor que cero ahora hay
otras maneras en las que yo puedo hacer
al producto negativo entonces supongamos
que tengo tres números
el signo de a es positivo el signo de
vez negativo y el signo de c es positivo
entonces al multiplicar estos números
tenemos a por b eso es negativo por
positivo esto aprobé es negativo y
negativo por positivo eso es negativo
entonces todo esto será negativo
así que bueno si hay veces son números
negativos el producto será negativo pero
este fue el caso de tres números qué
pasaría si yo tengo cuatro números
entonces qué pasaría si yo a este
producto lo multiplicó por un número de
supongamos que estos cuatro números son
números negativos entonces supongamos
que que a es negativo b es negativo que
es negativo y d es negativo
todos son negativos y la multiplicación
la puedo hacer en cualquier orden pero
vamos a empezar de izquierda a derecha
entonces empecemos la multiplicación de
izquierda a derecha empecemos con a&b
entonces a por b tenemos 2 negativos eso
es un positivo la multiplicación de dos
negativos te da un positivo y si
multiplicamos eso por c donde ese es un
negativo tenemos positivo por negativo
esto te da un negativo entonces a por b
por ser
eso es negativo
y lo multiplicamos luego por de donde d
es un negativo entonces tenemos negativo
por negativo eso es positivo por lo
tanto todo esto a por b por ser por d es
positivo entonces tal vez aquí ya puedes
ver un patrón si multiplicas muchos
números y tienes una cantidad imparten
negativos cantidad imparten negativos
que estás multiplicando dividiendo
entonces tienes una cantidad impar de
negativos qué sucede
bueno aquí yo hice yo hice esto para
multiplicación pero también es cierto si
si estos signos fueran de división así
tú tienes una cantidad impar de
negativos en tu producto o en tu
cociente entonces el resultado será
negativo entonces el resultado es
negativo
si tienes ahora una cantidad parte
negativos una cantidad par de negativos
entonces tu resultado será positivo
tenemos una cantidad par de negativos
entonces tenemos que el producto o el
cociente será positivo toda la expresión
será positivo entonces tú puedes
visualizar esto como una generalización
de lo que acabamos de ver positivo por
positivo ahí tienes 0 negativos
cero es un número par entonces esto es
positivo
ahora negativo por negativo eso es una
cantidad par de negativos entonces
tenemos otra vez el caso en el que
cantidad par de negativos nos da un
positivo
y entonces en esos dos casos tendrás un
positivo como resultado ahora en estos
casos tienes un negativo en cualquiera
de ellos tiene solamente un negativo
entonces tienes una cantidad de impar de
negativos
el resultado será negativo y podemos
usar esos conocimientos para trabajar
con números negativos y exponentes
entonces si yo digo que tengo un número
a y lo elevó la potencia 101 entonces
tengo un número a y lo elevó a la
potencia 101 y supongamos que a es un
número negativo entonces estás tomando
101 así los estás multiplicando pero 101
es un número impar entonces estás
multiplicando un número negativo un
número impar de veces por lo tanto el
resultado será negativo tú podrías
multiplicar 101 veces a pero sabemos
sabemos resultado será negativo entonces
bueno intentemos con otro ejemplo vamos
a tomar
un número a negativo
un número a menor que cero y un número
menor que cero ahora supongamos que lo
estamos elevando a la potencia 101 y lo
dividimos entre ve a la séptima potencia
esto será positivo negativo o tal vez
sea 0 veamos entonces el numerador este
es un número un número impar de números
negativos que se están multiplicando eso
es negativo en el denominador tenemos un
número impar de negativos que se están
multiplicando entonces también es
negativo
y negativo / negativo un número negativo
entre otro número negativo eso es igual
a un número positivo por lo tanto esto
es igual a un número positivo y
terminamos